i said hey man you know isn't that seen
fantastic and he said what scene
marvel movie cgi is some of the best but
just how much of it is used to amp up
the epic fights we're checking out 15 of
the most impressive battles that see
actors pulling off some wild stunts
while needing cgi to perfect that image
number one
why fight inside a building when there's
perfectly good scaffolding outside while
the actors weren't really battling
multiple floors up in the air the
scaffolding area was built for the
performers to leap in battle through
blue surrounding them everywhere was key
to filling in this environment aside
from the setting pretty much all of what
we see is courtesy of pure talent the
training to get into shape for this
acrobatic action was long but so worth
it for the full out performance of this
fight i really do think it's an
ever-evolving thing and a company that
isn't afraid to lean into spontaneity
sometimes surely there are more
comfortable ways of getting to a lower
floor no mercy was shown and no way home
as spider-man actually went through the
floor to pull off this stunt the stunt
coordinating team for this spider-man
flick is capable of bringing wild
moments to the screen and in this case
they did not hold back all they needed
were some wires a harness and fearless
performers when you get given an
opportunity like this you'd be a bit of
an idiot if you didn't go for it no
matter where they are nothing will stop
them from duking out a good fight
accomplishing this whole battle sequence
took filming in several parts
all that air action
cool as it was it was all performed on
land before cgi black widow herself
whipped out those moves in full and then
let the cg team take over and put all
the parts together i'm really proud of
it we didn't we did a lot of hard work
on it time to fly through different
realities get your seatbelts on this
fight could not have happened with that
cgi these graphics throw us for just as
much of a loop as tom holland sometimes
he had a spidey suit and for the more
unnerving moments of suit changes it was
mocap all the way with so many elements
in the sequence some of the really
striking visuals were fully digitally
constructed shots the image of mysterio
taking hold of mj went through a ton of
privilege to make sure they could
accomplish the haunting moment properly
zendaya was much safer filming her
portion in studio but she still got a
boost from some wires this is a
spider-man movie like this is like
action like it's going down when they
assemble they do it well
every portal itself of course wasn't
present but those performers were and
when they stormed onto the set they went
full tilt sometimes that meant going
wild stabbing at a green pad while a lot
of performers were on set at the time it
was never to the full scope of what we
see since they divided everyone up into
separate groups to shoot and later put
it all together pretty much every stage
of the cg in this battle looks amazing
these two duked it out only partially
suited up in the studio free to bring
that battle to life while their setting
was much less chaotic than what we see
on screen they still included some handy
practical tricks like this little moving
platform to allow the actors to move
easily so these shots could be used with
just a bit of cg added for the final
movie they may not be wearing their
actual costumes but honestly these black
suits set up to track their performances
really do the trick and all that
practical lighting well it's pretty easy
to see the magic just from this
if the studio is going to put everything
they can into it i have to give marvel
credit
and disney credit man vs drone it's
never a pretty sight tom holland wasn't
only in the studio to film this he
swapped his spidey suit for a mocap suit
too luckily he wasn't really facing
drones intricate mapping was done to
make sure they all moved around and
interacted with holland properly and did
they ever know how to swarm all the
details we see from the explosions to
swarming drones to the tower bridge and
spider-man whipping through all the
chaos were a beautiful amalgamation of
some of the most realistic cg we've ever
seen
they were like cut yeah that was
incredible
um and it's in the movies i think it's
in the movie anyway caution folks major
action ahead
everything from the electricity pulsing
through him to parts of his suit were
cgi rendered facing off with anyone
coming at him wasn't so intimidating
since he was rocking the thor look while
they were kitted out with mocap suits
but that didn't dampen their
performances one bit with the epic
proportions of this battle cgi took care
of the most intense details you know
like giant fiery creatures ripping
through the land it was a wonderful
experience
number nine
sure they both had the ten rings in the
movie but on the set one big ring gave
simulu the extra boost he needed to defy
gravity and smoothly work his magic with
those rings the layers of detail added
are endless with cg done for each of the
individual rings and then of course
embellishing the image with epic
lighting and the powerful glow simu took
advantage of a harness at one point as
well to really nail this pose the
connection between the rings and the
actors movements is just flawless
i'll help you i'll develop a whole style
based on your abilities who's ready to
tear up this tarmac just because cgi
completed these images and made the
battle epic as it was let's not ignore
the fact that the action was very real
as the performers ran through the lot
next to some very real explosions while
he didn't get to control a full ship
chris evans did get a partial build to
give him the perfect setting to bring
his valiant performance as for jeremy
renner well he was all bow and no arrow
i guess here i am doing it right epic
battle time in three two one considering
how intense the fight is it's no
surprise there were multiple shooting
days in a few different locations to
capture it all the marvel team went out
into the real world to shoot and found
beauty in the natural landscape
only amped up by cg in the final cut to
add to the epic nature they brought
everyone along to film there was water
explosions and full-out battles
happening while actors were in mocap
suits like a true fan because i didn't
know that a certain thing was going to
happen how this bus survived we have no
idea while they weren't really racing
down a highway this bus was the real
deal and simulu well he's as real as it
gets all those months hitting the gym
and doing all that stretching did him
well when filming this feisty fight
especially that split kick a blue studio
went a long way for the cg masterminds
that created the busy environment
convincing us that the city got wrecked
by all this shanxi power fighting just
seeing superheroes where there were not
superheroes before was such an
empowering moment actors are important
for scenes but in this case a giant
puppet played a key role the arena
itself is a sight to see and that was
all thanks to cg that included a hundred
and sixty thousand audience members the
actor was on his own filming his portion
for the most part the closest he got to
actually battling the real hulk was
facing off with a bust of the character
set eight and a half feet high and
maneuvered by vfx techs mark ruffalo did
his mocap performance with a
head-mounted camera solo for just his
facial expressions to be captured
anytime these two actually made contact
was merely a cgi
creation just finally see it done is
pretty pretty cool hey team we're taking
to the streets
no blue studios in sight these actors
had nothing but some pads between them
and the pavement if anything even the
cap shield came out for the occasion
plenty of time was spent planning out
how they'd capture each shot especially
making sure they got the best angles
while the performers were hooked up to
wires and leveling up their performances
like nobody's business before they got
to actually filming the rehearsals ran
on making sure every moment was perfect
number 15
rocket raccoon rocked out as a cgi
creature while the performers got their
parts captured live in studio they may
not really be in space but every object
was carefully mapped out in accordance
to how it would move and power through
space giving us a chaotic but freakishly
real battle and then of course there's
this moment it was less slimy in reality
but hey it did the trick
these fights definitely wouldn't be as
impactful without the incredible vfx
used to bring the magic but behind the
scenes is just as fascinating to see
which scene did you dig the live shoot
for